[Música]
[Aplausos]
boa noite ele falará do tema supressão e
queria dizer que no dicionário que via
parceiro e já está a aparecer
temos três coisas muito próximas mas
também distintas em primeiro lugar
superação passar mais além do que galgar
ultrapassar obter uma vitória
relativamente a vencer ser superior o
melhor super um dos grandes pensadores
dos nossos tempos o eduardo lourenço é
de uma terra ainda mais fina do que
nossa eu é do mal da área do interior da
guarda e dizia qualquer coisa como da
minha aldeia eu consigo ver mais fria
seca conseguia para lá daquelas
montanhas e daquelas montanhas ver
liberdades ver a oportunidade de ver
algo mais e conseguiu ver um dos maiores
filósofos da europa conseguiu sem perder
suas raízes da terra conseguiu dispersá
ao longo da minha carreira
nos últimos anos tem feito grandes
reportagens que todas elas curiosamente
não foi dado conta falou exatamente
disso da vida e da superação das pessoas
são temas diferentes mas todas elas
tocam uma explorar determinação outras
presidência
o transpor não ter medo de enfrentar o
desconhecido mas todas elas são de
pessoas superaram em junho deste ano
fiz uma grande reportagem a última que
fiz chamou renascer das cinzas
um ano depois eu voltei ao 27 de junho
que todos nós vivemos com um olhar
triste para que o que se passou em troca
grandes há precisamente um ano atrás
quando eu acho que cai tinha não tinha
nada
eu não ouvi o barulho da natureza
eu não ouvi a chocar com um pássaro
o vento das folhas das árvores e não
ouvia vida em cada esquina que eu
passava havia alguém que tinha privada
em enviar alguém que tinha perdido a
casa vi alguém que tenha perdido os
animais havia alguém que tinha perdido
seus tempos de uma vida mas no entanto
nunca houve uma daquelas pessoas naquela
situação tão frágil tão dura tão injusta
nunca ouvi ninguém dizer que desistiria
este ano voltei lá foi com as mesmas
pessoas e vi no olhar daquela gente
determinação coragem ea resiliência e
orgulho de estar alguém no interior tão
esquecido
tem muitas vezes tomava nato do governo
central
vamos ver
eu to falando como esse aqui o
percurso fortes ganhos isto foi há um
ano
ainda dói dói muito bom num caminho pela
frente são cicatrizes que estão na alma
e por onde quer que se olha todas na
região ainda sofre menos
é uma luta diária mas só o fato de eu
ter alguém a luta continua
eu acredito que castanheira por muito
mal que tenha passado o potencial
continua cá e nós só precisamos de gente
com o espírito e força de vontade que
consiga fazer a castanheira financeira
kite implantá lo de imediato não gostar
espero que ontem puxaram a frente se
referindo
nós somos o orgulho de rosas do ambiente
i devemos nada bom
agora voltarei online depois as pessoas
lembravam os de mim mesmo na angústia
que o momento difícil lembrar avance
porque eles têm voz e porque escutai
como tantos outros naquela aflição
eu sempre estive na memória e durante
este ano curtem muito da força da
resiliência e que este povo está
habituado aos focos verão traz drão ao
frio a chuva a geada a neve ea partida
ganhava aqui este interior tão perto do
litoral sabem o que é a indiferença do
poder político de queimada e sempre
mandou em lisboa
mas apesar das adversidades ser
português é muito disto no silêncio faz
inventa e reinventa e sabe que esta
gente ainda no meio das cinzas vai
continuar a construir este portugal
em alguns momentos nós nos identificamos
porque o que vamos dizer e ouvir e é
como eu dizia nós temos no interior e
está no páreo aqui estamos a ter algumas
dificuldades que a internet consiga
andar a mesma ansiedade que nós pedimos
e diz já sus
vamos falar de uma outra história é esta
em 2016 uma temática diferente mas que
fala também de superação determinação de
coragem exemplos inspiradores
fiz uma grande corrida a gente chamava o
lugar onde o ficai retrata a vida dos
retornados de angola aea 75 durante a
guerra da independência
imaginem vocês aqui estão aqui sentados
confortavelmente chegam a vossas casas e
amanhã a vossa revirado no aves ficam
sem ver os amigos sem ver a família tem
que ser correr de casa muito só com a
roupa do corpo sem os nossos animais sem
as nossas potências têm as nossas raízes
até porque muitas dessas pessoas não
tinham nascido cá tinham nascido na
espanha se fosse em angola são tomé cabo
verde moçambique guiné e estas pessoas
conseguiram vir para um país com 10
estranho e conseguiram dar a volta
[Música]
com a vida já feitas o filho criava os
movimentos ao colo
muitos continuam a ter na alma o lugar
onde ficaram a mais de 40 anos fazemos
amiga são tomé e cabo verde guiné angola
o desgaste o capítulo
não
eu acho que falar misto
pra mim é uma catarse
[Música]
o livina de certa forma
mas é verdade que evita ainda rui da
versão essa faça nível
por cá muita coisa que desapareceu
o que é este episódio eo destruiu da
minha vida
e no entanto eu sou dos que tiveram só
conseguiu conseguiram fazer quase
totalmente a sua vida em portão
quando pensa na sua terra nas raízes o
que a sua terra sua identidade sem água
[Música]
sinto eu até costumo dizer capitalizando
preto
esta história foi tão intensa e estas
pessoas trouxeram tanto ajudaram tanto
que chega profissionalmente quer
pessoalmente que vai escrever um livro
hora da partida
no ano passado sobre esta gente como
dizia joão um país estranho mas
conseguiu ainda ajudar a construir um
conseguiu trazer idéias novas e alguma
coisa uns então quem ainda se vivia
então na altura kofi novas ideias novos
mundos dentro deste nosso mundo falar no
tórax agora tchau pra mim foi mais do
que um trabalho é uma história com
marcou particularmente fez melhor pessoa
sem dúvida trama melhor pessoa que
talvez a história mais significante mais
simbólica superação
fui que eu aprendi o que é superação
um dia estava eu na que os dias menos
felizes os meus pequenos problemas e eu
gosto muito de caminhadas malawi junto
ao jejum sem marítimo na zona da hora
estava numa praia do araçagi repente
pararam o que toda a gente me pára na
rua não sou eu só que as pessoas
preferem ignorar com dois sem abrigo
dois homens vivem debaixo de um viaduto
na entrada do haras passam milhares e
milhares de cartas e centenas de pessoas
todos os dias
hum um português de 70 anos para um
fernando
cinquenta e tal que por circunstâncias
menos felizes da vida acabam por criar
uma amizade que era de todo improvável
o trabalho não desmente medo mas as
marias da vida por vezes são mais
ingratas numerosas e as oportunidades
são os mais conhecimentos no lugar
certos estão condicionadas por rótulos e
referências de bin laden e seguir em
frente
não sou capaz de te vi nada nem ninguém
o espeço época ganhando necessidades que
o faz tem muita fome por fazer e apesar
de viverem debaixo desta ponte continua
com a esperança de que os dias e as
noites deixem de ser opção aqui nesta
fugiu que encontraram para passar melhor
um dos momentos mais complicados que o
país atravessa um sonho pra mim era ter
uma casa para abrigar os meus filhos
quando eles querem e para mim também já
tomou cartões não quero estar a dormir
numa boa
já passou um mês e nunca mais os vi por
causa das rotinas do da via
sempre que passo por aqui recorda o pan
eo fernando duas pessoas que o receberam
bem desde o primeiro momento o pouco que
tinha
partilhar onde há uma aberta
é por isso que o que é meu amigo
agora nem prefeito é vergonhoso um
cinzento destes dias assim há exemplos
de pessoas dignas educadas inteiras que
não desistem opção desculpam com as
circunstâncias da vida que o empurrou
para debaixo de uma ponte aqui 11 é
fácil distinguir a dignidade é um lugar
estranho
[Música]
estes dois órgãos mas para vocês terem
uma idéia de você lá há algumas noites
em alguns dias com eles vive é que os
viam comia que os que comiam quando
havia comida estamos a falar de pessoas
que vivem ao relento a frio a chover as
filmagens foram feitas em frágil havia
de fato muito tempo atrás como as altas
com ratos sem saber se vão ter uma moça
vão ter um jantar e ainda assim como eu
dizia receberam de braços abertos se não
se for um sorriso pra andar não sempre
um pacote de esparguete quando algum
vizinho dava para dividir comigo e eu
ao final do dia e para casa tinha o
aquecimento central à minha espera o
edredom fofinho um banho quente e foi
nessas alturas em investimentos em que
eu realmente percebi o que é superação
eo vista e os grevistas somos muitas
vezes quando achamos que estamos
prevendo o fim do mundo e os nossos
problemas são tão em fios e tão fáceis
de contornar e são essas pessoas que nos
dão coragem e que nos fazem entender que
nós somos capazes de tudo
vamos fazer o impossível possível muitas
partidas e foi até aqui partidas
as partidas da nossa terra mas também
falou das pessoas que estão aqui que
vivem aqui passam por essas pressão
todos os dias seja para ir à américa
vila real porto seja para ele tratar de
assuntos burocráticos e ter que ir a
viseu saja depararem se com falta de
emprego com as distâncias com a cultura
a cultura
felizmente temos aqui este teatro do
paulo é muito lembra que ser pequenina
vir aqui ao just de chita aos concursos
muitos de vocês se lembram com certeza
na senhora dos remédios mas sim até à
cultura até aqui estava tão inacessível
quero com isto dizer que o meu verbo é o
ir
mas eu irei sempre voltar à minha casa
eles sempre voltar ao flamengo espero
ter superado este desafio sobretudo as
nossas expectativas
obrigado